foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I want to go over some of the new
information regarding how so the
dragon's second season and how this may
affect the show as a whole as you all
know HBO will begin filming House of the
dragon's second season very soon in fact
they should have already started filming
their episodes in March but for one
reason or another it was delayed for a
few more weeks HBO's filming on House of
the Dragon should begin any day now as
we're all waiting for any new
information about the show deadline
revealed some new details about House of
the dragon's second season that sent
shock waves throughout the fandom now
according to their new article the
second season of House of the Dragon
will be shorter than its first as HBO
looks for a green light for season three
and I gotta be honest I was not
expecting this at all I assumed House of
the dragon's second season would have
the same amount of episodes as their
first season but I guess HBO is already
switching things up and moving things
around this very well could have a major
effect on the series as a whole
considering it will alter the structure
of the story as we all know the first
season of House of the Dragon already
felt very rushed because they had to go
over roughly 30 years of events and only
10 episodes now that we know the second
season will only have eight episodes you
have to wonder how will this affect
everything moving forward now thankfully
we shouldn't have to worry about any
more gaps in the story now that we're
finally at the beginning of the dance of
the Dragons the rest of the series
should unfold like your standard show
without us having to worry about missing
years worth of events after each episode
now deadlines article says this new
information comes as production is about
to begin on season 2 in the UK in what
is a relatively common practice HBO did
not reveal the episode order in the
season 2 renewal announcement last
summer deadline hears that the initial
strategy was for another 10 episode Arc
which eventually changed leading to some
script rewrites given the leadership
change at HBO's parent company some
blame Warner Brothers Discovery
leaderships focused on cost cutting in
HBO spokesperson who confirmed a
deadline That season 2 will only contain
Eight Episodes stressed that the episode
count trim was story driven now it has
been reported that the house of the
dragon's creative team had envisioned
the series running for three or four
seasons they said that showrunner Ryan
Condell working with author and
executive producer George RR Martin took
a step back as season 2 was being put
together to take a big picture view of
the series which as we all know follows
George RR Martin's Fire and Blood and
they're figuring out the overall
narrative flow including how to break up
the Story season to season and what
battles to include and when now deadline
also hears That season 3 has been mapped
out it might be green lighted with HBO
seriously considering committing to
moving ahead with Scripps casting and a
production plan as the network too is
trying to think long term instead of
season to season now with some of the
story originally intended for season 2
including a major battle moving to
season three they hear that it is now
more likely the series would run for
Four Seasons but that has not been
determined as condo and Martin continue
to go back and forth on the number of
Seasons they're trying to figure out
what would be optimal to tell the full
story the sources said now in one of his
not a Blog updates back in October
George RR Martin spoke of the fact that
HBO series like The Sopranos used to get
13 episodes a season which had then
changed to 10 by the time Game of
Thrones came along the Emmy winning
Fantasy Juggernaut did release 6-10
episode Seasons leading into the final
13 episode chapter that was split into
two this is more than the eight episode
seasons of Amazon's Lord of the Rings
series he noted now if all of you
remember and one of George R Martin's
not a Blog updates he said I am thrilled
to still have 10 hours every season to
tell artel I hope that will continue to
be true it will take four full seasons
of 10 episodes each to do justice to the
dance of the dragons from start to
finish as you all know George R Martin
is the author of Fire and Blood and A
Song of Ice and Fire no one and I mean
no one knows it better than him it
wasn't that long ago when he wrote that
blog saying House of the Dragon will
need four full seasons of 10 episodes
each to do justice to the dance of the
dragons from start to finish and well
now HBO is already having them shorten
the second season to only eight episodes
this obviously means that something is
about to be left out of the show I'm
hoping they don't go down the same road
as Game of Thrones did where they just
start rushing through everything to get
to the end I still believe that Ryan
Condell will want to do a faithful
adaptation you also have to keep in mind
that just because the season is losing a
few episodes doesn't always mean the
season has to be shorter overall maybe
they will make those Eight Episodes
longer than your standard Game of
Thrones or House of the Dragon episode
if they do make some of them over an
hour long then we can still get 10 hours
of story George R Martin believes we
will need for the dance of the Dragons
now as a fan of the show I never want to
hear that we're getting less episodes
but it doesn't have to mean we will get
less story as I've said they still might
find a way to give us 40 hours of House
of the Dragon one way or another so
although this does sound like bad news
at first I'm not going to get overly
worried just yet maybe each of the Eight
Episodes will be longer or maybe season
3 or 4 will have a dozen episodes it is
still a little too early to know how
this will affect the show as a whole as
always I will make sure you're kept up
to date on any new interesting
information about House of the dragon
and all of the other Game of Thrones
shows HBO has in development let me know
what all of you think about this
information down below what do you think
this means for the future of House of
the Dragon let me know your thoughts
about this new article from deadline
once again I have to thank all of you
for watching another one of my videos I
hope all of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon bye
foreign
[Music]